look I'm not gonna lie to you this is
probably gonna be a really short review
you got better things to do what game
are you playing right now Street Fighter
6 Diablo 4 tears of the Kingdom what a
year for games let's make it quick
talking about a Jennifer Lawrence
raunchcom here we go
[Music]
so no hard feelings Stars Jennifer
Lawrence and feels like a raunch comedy
from 2005 released in 2023. Jennifer
Lawrence plays an Uber driver Who's down
on her luck her bills are piling up she
loses her car so she sees an ad in which
these two parents are like hey our 19
year old son is really socially awkward
have sex with him the car is yours first
of all
Lawrence this is new for her right she's
done drama Sci-Fi Action movies now
raunchcom and she actually is good in
the movie not everything in the movie
lands generally speaking not all the
comedy does lens very physical movies a
lot of slapstick in here but she does
make it work you can tell she's not a
comedian by trade she doesn't have years
of comedies just Stacks in the echelon
of the archives of her life and
entertainment to bring up the slapstick
and the physical comedy because by
contrast that's not what worked in here
she really worked when she was being
comedically awkward but like when she
first meets the dude at his work at a
Veterinary Clinic and she's trying to be
sexy and it's really awkward like that's
that was great also the dude her date
Andrew Barth Feldman I thought he was a
comedic standout in here I thought he
was fantastic he's the one who really
stuck the landing on that physical
comedy I felt he's socially awkward and
that endearingly sweet been sheltered
his entire life because helicopter
parents kind of way he almost feels
Mormon a couple of my Mormon fans I felt
her through the ether you were like wait
a minute take a minute you really think
about that and you will think to
yourself
but that is fetching true that set would
not be surprised if the original draft
was so 32 year old woman wants to [__] a
19 year old Mormon for a car what do you
say I mean he's got to be a genuine dude
that we can root for and relate to it's
not really her she she's not the heart
and soul of the movie he is she's
actually kind of an [__] but that's
the point of the movies at the core of
this movie there's there's a story of
The Human Experience human connection
he's going to learn from her she's going
to learn from him yes in terms of the
Romantic angle you know exactly how this
is going to go down there were things
that were Silly in the movie not in that
hey it's a comedy supposed to laugh but
things that didn't logistically make
sense they were just ridiculous but in
terms of laughs that's where the movie
is really held back it is a comedy and I
never had that belly laugh type moment
not that I didn't laugh it was just a
series of Chuckles but I was surprised
that a movie with this premise was made
in 2023 I had thought to myself could
they make American Pie today it's not
about that pretty recently actually my
answer in my head was probably not but I
guess it can still be made as long as
there's a transaction as long as the
parents are paying for it I guess
American Pie can still be made but this
movie did feel like a weird little ranch
comedy Time Capsule like it came from
the mid-2000s the American Pie movies
had wrapped up we had Wedding Crashers
and then this movie that got shelved and
forgotten and someone was like oh yeah
let's make that now movie was cute
predictable enjoyable I chuckled I had
myself a good time I'm gonna say a good
time no alcohol required Again Play it
safe at matinee price all right so no
hard feelings have you seen it what did
you think about it what's your favorite
comedy or raunch comedy I don't know
favorite comedy in the last 20 years man
I'm putting a lot of logistics what's
your favorite raunch comedy we'll keep
it simple whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]